I guess they call themselves in cells,
involuntary celibates when all this
stuff went down with his car,
drove his car into a group of people.
It's horrible tragedy.
I'm one of the things that you talked
about within cells is that,
and this was a part of the role,
what was it?
The News in New York Times piece you,
you said one of the cures for this is
enforced monogamy.
People decided and you know,
I had never heard that term before quite
honestly,
and I was like,
Whoa,
what the fuck does that mean?
It's a psychological term and what it
means is enforced by culture that it is
a good value.
Monogamy,
polygamy.
Polygamous societies tend to become
ultra violent.
Yeah.
That's been known in the anthropological
literature for one Hundred Years and
certainly leftist anthropologists were
among those who discovered it,
like she knew the journalist knew
perfectly well.
What I meant by enforcement,
Augie,
she has got a stupid.
It's a.
You use it as if everybody would
understand it because you're an
intellectual and because you're a
professor and you do.
It was also two minutes out of a two day
conversation.
So if that's how she glanced over,
well,
it's so funny.
That was funny in some sense because my
sense is if you want to pillory someone
you should attribute to them views that
someone somewhere has had and the
implication of that part of the New York
Times article was that I wanted to take
new bile,
young women at the point of a gun
understate enforcement and deliver them
to useless man.
It's like no one has ever believed that
trinity sounds like that.
It's a real.
The optics of that statement are very
bad,
but the question is why didn't.
Why wasn't their followup questions and
if there was followup questions to get
you to define what you mean by
enforcement on there were they just
didn't make it into the piece.
That's a real problem.
Yeah,
it's a real problem.
That's a real problem because that's
what that is.
It's so ridiculous because inaccurate
definition of who you are.
One of the things I've said continually,
and this is on record in multiple
places,
it's like,
okay,
so you're a young man and all the women
are rejecting you.
Who's got the problem?
It's not all the women.
That's a bad road to go down if all the
women are rejecting you,
it's you.
We both agree on this,
but why is enforced monogamy the
solution for people that are involuntary
celibates?
Well,
it's the solution to the.
It's the solution to the relationship
between men and women.
Fundamentally is monogamous.
Social men are unattractive if these on
attraction to them,
but these men are unattractive to women.
I don't mean just physically
unattractive mean women aren't seeking
them as mates.
They need to become men.
Yes,
they certainly.
This is the solution that's the
solution.
Absolutely.
We both agree on this,
so what they need to do that in a
society where monogamy is the social
norm but isn't the social norm anyway?
Well,
that was partly my point,
although to the degree that we deviate
from that,
we tilt towards a more violent society.
I was making a very minor point.
I don't think they're related.
Quite honestly,
I don't think that involuntary
celibates.
I don't think that having enforced
monogamy as a part of our cultural norm
is going to help those people are really
just how's it going to help them?
Well,
because what happens is if a polygamous
society develops,
which is the alternative,
then a small minority of men get all the
women.
That's what happened.
That's the only point in this theory,
theoretical world where polygamous
societies exist and mass and then you do
have this problem with a small group of
men that are fucking all the women,
but that's not.
And also making the women unhappy.
Right?
Because the women don't have any access
to a genuine intimate one to one
relationship over any long period of
time,
which just doesn't work well.
It's the whole idea is and what's best
for sure if you have children.
Right,
but I still don't think that that is why
these men are involuntary celibates and
I don't think it's the solution to that.
I think the solution is that they need
to become attractive.
Yes,
that is the solution is no doubt.
I don't.
I don't think the two are related.
Well,
the only.
I was making a minor point.
The minor point was that one of the ways
that societies around the world have
figured out that you keep young male
aggression under control is by enforcing
monogamous standards because it gives
everyone a chance,
in some sense,
only point meant meaning.
It clears more,
uh,
more women will be available for one on
one relationships rather than one guy
who is,
you know,
whatever,
for whatever reasons,
figure in society when you see this
happening in universities where women
outnumber men,
so the man hypothetically have more
sexual opportunity,
but that isn't what happens.
What happens is that a small minority of
men have all the sexual opportunity.
A fairly large minority of men don't.
The women are unhappy because they can't
find a committed relationship.
It's bad for most of the men and the men
who have all the sexual opportunity get
cynical,
but isn't this in some ways against your
whole idea of equality of outcome
because you're,
you're talking about equality of sexual
outcome.
Now,
if these men,
if you see that Guy James,
that's the dominant basketball player
that just kicks everyone's ass.
This is the,
this,
this is a guy who succeeded at the
highest level,
right?
Well,
there's going to be people like that
sexually.
There's going to be people that are
better at finding mates and this is what
they enjoy.
They enjoy having many mates.
They enjoy being yes,
but,
but if this is what they enjoy,
if it's a man who doesn't want a family
and enjoys dating multiple women,
why is that bad?
Well,
I think the fundamental reason it's bad
is because it's bad in the long run for
children.
It's bad for children if he chooses to
have children.
Yeah.
Well that makes sense.
But that's it.
That's the fundamental mental
issue as far as I'm concerned right now.
I think it's the answer.
Look to give the journalist credit.
That is the point she was making,
you know,
apart from pillaring me and,
and,
and caricaturizing my perspective.
That was the point she was making.
Well,
first of all,
I'm not in favor of unbridled
hierarchies like already said that you
know,
the proclivity of a hierarchy is that
all the spoils go to the person at the
top and that can destabilize the whole
structure,
so we have to have a dialogue about how
to rectify that,
possibly rectified that.
If one man is like,
say if we've got one six foot five
beautiful man who's got a perfect body
and he's brilliant and he just wants to
date a bunch of women and all the rest
of the people or five foot one and
they're fat and they're lazy and like
this guy is gonna.
If this is the competition,
he's going to win.
Yeah,
Yep.
There's no way around this and even if
you decide to have enforced monogamy
where it becomes a popular thing,
the women are going to be more drawn to
him.
If he chooses to date them,
they might decide.
I would rather have him sometimes the
never actually what does happen,
but what is wrong with that?
Well,
what's wrong with it is that it
destabilized the society and it's bad
for children.
Right.
You said that that would have to have
children,
but there's a lot of people that don't
want to have children.
There's a lot of people that choose to
go their entire life without having
children.
There's men in their thirties.
One,
some of my friends dummies.
They don't want children.
So why?
Why would that help in any way?
These involuntary celibate?
Well,
I think you tilt the society so that it
serves the interests of.
Well,
that's a good question.
Do you,
but you've seen my point where I see
your point.
There's no doubt about it.
You're almost having.
You're almost forcing an inequality of.
I know that was her point to to the
degree that she had a point that was her
point now,
but it's not.
It doesn't run contrary to my opinions
that the issue of outcome has to be
addressed.
Already said there's needs to be a
reason for the left and the right,
and then the problem with hierarchies.
They can get to steep and destabilize
everything that does happen.
That particularly happens in the sexual
domain and there's plenty of
anthropological evidence for that,
but you still might say,
well,
who cares?
Because the man who are who are winning
should be allowed to win in the women
should be allowed to choose.
Yes,
except that there's the problem of
children and so society steps in on
behalf of the children and you can say,
well,
lots of people don't want to have
children.
Yes,
and that's truer now than it used to be.
Although many of those people end up
having children anyways,
you know the guys who snooping around
all the time,
so that doesn't circumvent the problem,
but the issue here for me isn't the man
or the women,
it's the children.
We're trying to set up societies where
the probability that children will be
raised in something approximating
optimal environment is optimized and
that's going to mean sacrifice of
opportunity and choice on the part of
the adults.
It's necessary.
I agree with you,
but I think that what we're talking
about mirrors what we're talking about
sports.
It mirrors what we're talking about in
business.
It's everything else.
There's going to be people that are
better at all different aspects of life.
talented in terms of like getting women
to like that.
Yes,
that's true,
but that's why also look,
you see this,
women are high pergamum,
which means they made up and they meet
across and up dominance hierarchies,
and so if you're a male who's successful
in a given hierarchy,
the probability that you're going to
have additional mating opportunities is
exceptionally high.
It's an unbelievably good predictor of
that.
That hypergo me is a very uncomfortable
discussion.
Certainly as well.
There's plenty of uncomfortable
discussions too.
That's a big one though.
It is the idea that it defines women's
sexual choices by the fact that they
want beggar bigger,
better want someone who's more more
successful,
someone who's higher on the social
ladder than what they're accustomed to
or what they have.
What women do is choice is a very
difficult problem.
So how do you solve that?
Well,
here's how women solve it.
Throw them in a ring.
Let them compete at whatever they're
competing at.
Assume that the man who wins is the best
man marry him.
Yes.
It's a brilliant solution.
It's a market oriented solution.
It's actually the solution that appears
to have driven our evolutionary
departure from chimpanzees.
It's a biological solution solution
which has a cost.
What is the cost?
The cost is the cost is polygamy,
and so we ran that in with enforced
monogamy and we do that in order to
provide stable,
stable circumstances for children.
Is polyamorous.
Is a polyamorous society just as
unattainable as this Utopian Marxist
idea?
I think so because it looks like,
and this is another point I was making
that didn't get covered in the article
that I wrote about it somewhat
extensively on my blog,
is that society's tilt towards monogamy
across the world is human universal.
Now,
that doesn't mean that people don't have
polygamous or polyamorous tendencies
because they certainly do and it
certainly also the case that one of the
ways that women Gerrymander this system
is that like the number of women and
children who are in a say say you're
married and you have children with your
husband,
but you also have an affair and so you
have a child by another mat that's more
common than anyone suspected,
so part of the way that women solve the
problem that you're just describing,
and I'm not saying anything for this or
against this,
this is a purely factual biological
claim,
is they pick a monogamous marriage and
they cheat with high status guys.
Now you know obviously in the confines
of the marriage,
that's a terrible thing,
but that's a very uncomfortable subject
though for women in particular,
uncomfortable subject for everyone,
but it's a terribly uncomfortable
subject.
They don't like the idea that this is a
common thing that women choose.
A safe man that is willing to be
monogamous with them and perhaps maybe
they're above him in a social class or
in a sexually,
and then they'll cheat with someone who
was above.
It's common,
but it's not the norm,
right?
It's still the norm.
Not to do that.
The norm is fidelity,
but.
But there's plenty of exception.
This is enforced monogamy,
culturally the norm.
This is the very definition of monogamy
is this.
It's like,
okay,
so my son is getting married in
September and so,
so let's say he comes to me in a year
and he says,
Hey dad,
guess what?
I've had three affairs in the last year
and they've all been successful.
I haven't got caught.
Aren't I a good guy?
What am I going to say to that?
Know what the hell are you doing?
That's not what you're supposed to be
doing.
That's enforced monogamy enforcement.
Origami meaning the people around you
try to guide them in a way that you
think is going to be harmonious.
Family,
yes.
It's built deep into the cultural norms
and if that starts to destabilize,
then there's trouble and that doesn't
mean that it's not prone to all the
problems that you laid out.
Look,
there isn't a bigger problem than
successful reproduction.
It is the big problem and all of the
solutions that we've generated for it
are full of flaws.